♪ ♪ ♪
- Faire les sucres, c'est
une tradition de génération
en génération chez la famille
Thivierge.
Et à quelques exceptions près,
on a conservé les méthodes
de travail d'autrefois.
MARTIN THIVIERGE, acériculteur
et producteur maraîcher
- Un peu comme mon grand père
le faisait. En fait, c'est sûr
qu'il y a des choses qu'on aamés
mettons avec un cheval,
maintenant c'est un quatre roues
avec des chenilles. On simplifie
la tâche un peu, mais disons que
la goutte qui sort du chalumeau,
elle se rend à la cabane presque
de la même manière.
- Raquettes aux pieds, ils vont
d'arbre en arbre pour cueillir
l'eau d'érable.
C'est 1700 chaudières à vider.
Ils apportent ensuite
le précieux liquide à la cabane
à sucre pour le transformer
en sirop.
- Pour nous, c'est presque
un peu des vacances, même si on
travaille quand même dur là,
mais c'est le fait de décrocher
un petit peu là.
Mon garçon vient d'arriver dans
le fond, il finit l'école,
il monte en motoneige, il nous
aide à ramasser. On va souper
à la cabane, t'sais, on va
rester ici jusqu'à 9 h ce soir.
- Martin Thivierge fait partie
d'un gr=
d'un groupe d'acériculteurs qui
souhaiteon
d'une appellation traditionnelle
pour le sirop fabriqué
à l'ancienne.
♪ ♪ ♪
Avocat dans la vie de tous
les jours, Stéphane Galibois
plaide lui aussi en faveur
d'une certification.
STÉPHANE GALIBOIS,
acériculteur et avocat
- Ça fait partie de notre
histoire au Québec, alors
cette façon de faire,
de récolter à la chaudière,
d'y aller doucement et d'avoir
lent produit. Alors,
c'est un petit peu tout ça
qu'on veut avoir avec
cette reconnaissance
du sirop traditionnel.
- Ça va être un bon sirop
aujourd'hui.
- Considéré comme une sommité
du domaine acéricole,
Stéphane Guay fait
du comité qui est derrière
le projet d'appellation.
STÉPHANE GUAY, acériculteur et
biologiste, Érable & Chalumeaux
- On a boir un témoir un témoirn
de ce que goûte un sirop fait
de façon traditionnel, parce
qu'avec tous les nouveaux
équipements, on a une dérive
de la saait, on a
une perte de la saveur
graduelle dans l'industrie.
- Pour qu'un sirop soit
considéré traditionnel, il yaurs
conditions à respecter.
L'eau d'érable dtddait
récoltée à la chaudière plutôt
qu'avec des tubes.
Il faudrait utiliser
un évaporateur alimenté par
un feu de bois pour la cuisson.
Et il serait interdit
de recourir à un système
de filtration pour concentrer
le sucre dans l'eau d'érable,
la faire
bouillir beaucoup moins
longtemps afin de la transformer
en sirop.
ps de résidence dans
l'évaporateur est beaucoup plus
court, puis ce temps
de résidence-là, bien, il est
t pour le développement
des saveurs. C'est un peu comme
pour n'importe quelle recette.
Si tu décides de faire des fèves
puis tu les cuis 20
minutes, tes fèves au lard, bien
il y a a bien des chances
qu'elles ne goûtent pas celles
de ta grand-mère.
- Je compare souvent avec
un rosbif qu'on ferait cuire
dans un micro-ondes ou bien
l'autre qu'on ferait cuirependar
que j'ai pas besoin
de convaincre personne que
la cuisson lente va être
meilleure, il va aoppé
des goûts. C'est la même chose
pour le sirop.
- Martin Thivierge pense qu'une
certification permettrait
de mettre en marché le sirop
d'érable traditionnel plus
facilement. Selon lui,
il pourrait être vendu 50% plus
cher que le sirop nel
qu'on retrouve dans
les épiceries.
- Les gens, ils ont le même
portefeuille pour l'achatde leus
comprennent que c'est
une qualité supérieure,
je pense... puis aussi pour
encourager les plus petits
producteurs, c'est souvent fait
à plus petite échelle quand
même, fait que je pense que
c'est des bonnes raisons.
- Il pourrait cert
valoir le double du sirop qu'on
retrouve un peu partout, qui est
fait à la tubulure.
- Ça va être un marché très
i va être destiné
aux gens curieux qui veulent
goûter une fois dans leur vie
c'est quoi le travail fait
de A jusqu'à Z.
- Stéphane Galibois croit que
les consommateurs qui se
laisseront tenter par le sirop
nnel ne ponnel ne ponnel ne pons
revenir en arrière.
- Ce qui est le sirop supérieur,
c'est lorsquizçHíHXH]ik/v# très.
Et là on l'apprécie, c'est
particulier, c'est l'érable,
c'est notre produit.
- Le premier volet, c'est
la saveur. Le deuxième volet,
c'est de protéger
En fait, c'est un savoir faire
qu'on veut que les gens gardent.
L'idée derrière ça c'est de sed,
le sirop va se vendre plus cher
puis il va y avoir de plus
en plus de monde qui vont
en faire à la chaudière.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les producteurs déposeront
leur demande au Conseildes appes
d'ici le début de l'automne.
Ils espèrent que leur sirop
d'érable pourra arborer
fièrement la certification
traditionnelle lors de
la prochaine saison des sucres.
ICI Olivier Bachand, Radio-C Re
d'Orléa